thank you
well good morning welcome to early
morning sessions I'm glad all of you are
here hope you had loads of coffee
I'll make sure they keep you awake
these are some of the URLs you actually
might want to keep it open on your tab
I had put instructions in the schedule
to have your laptop set up if you really
wanted to follow along
I would recommend not to do it now
because you're going to be spending some
time and given that we have we have a
big group over here everybody
downloading and installing on the laptop
could be a diversion so I really want to
concentrate on on the workshop today I'm
going to walk through
the introduction and I'll walk through
this walk through the notebooks myself
and since this is something that you can
actually take home with you if you need
sleeping aids tonight you can probably
use the tutorials it'll actually help
you
so let's get started again welcome this
is going to be a session about
introduction to Rey for distributed
computing and machine learning using
python basically we had Pi data actually
makes sense to do that
and I just want to get to know
what your background is and where you're
from so I can sort of understand and
calibrate the presentation so how many
of you actually have heard about rape
good you guys can go home then
how many of you are using Ray
good that you can stay
how many of you consider yourself data
scientist
I mean if you consider yourself machine
learning
how many you consider jumping on the
bandwagon to be model
foundational builders
okay
and I'm going to ask you a
tongue-in-check question how many of you
are python experts here
it's like going to a Catholic church and
asking is a proper Catholic you know
well welcome thank you very much
my name is Jules damji I am a lead
developer Advocate at engine scale uh
part of the ray team very much embedded
in the ray engineering team and prior to
that I was a senior developer at
um any at databricks where I spent about
six years contributing to Apache spark
and and mo flow and then prior to that I
was at hortonworks doing very much the
same thing and then prior that I held
many software engineering positions at
some of the notable companies so I was
very fortunate I was very very pleased
to be at the right time at the right
moment to really see the evolution of
this
fourth Evolution we're actually having
called foundational models so I think I
think this is actually great to be part
of it just been very fortunate to be
part of this particular Journey
who do I work for I work for a company
called any scale and we were the
original creators of Ray and Ray sort of
emerged from Berkeley's rice lab which
was a successor to the amp lab and where
Spark was born
tachyon was born mesos was born a cafe
was born so these were sort of the what
I would call the Berkeley's Innovation
Labs where they were very tied much of
the industry and these were the open
source projects that that were born and
what do we do you know what is our
addition well we provide you the unified
platform to deploy and manage your
scalable python applications and why do
we do that our mission really is to make
sure that scaling is today a necessity
it's not an exception and we want to
make sure that anybody in this
particular room with a python programmer
can actually take advantage of that it
used to be the case in the early days
where you actually had to be a
distributed machine learning or
distributed software developer to know
the internals of that we wanted to sort
of be abstracted the way and make that a
possibility for everyone because scaling
is is a necessity in scaling is
difficult
so here's the agenda what I'm going to
cover today give you sort of an
intuition of why and what Ray is and
rates ecosystem
and then we'll drop down into
re-architecture and components and what
are some of the
individual record design scaling
patterns that actually make this
actually possible and you can't be at a
conference today and not talk about
foundational models and not talk about
generative Ai and I just wanted to sort
of touch on just a little diversion
about how rare fits into the generative
Ai and we just consider large language
model that's just one of the workloads
that you can actually use to Ray and one
of the interesting bit about that the
companies who build this foundational
models such as cohere and open AI they
use Rey initially to to train and tune
these models and then we'll go in a
class for modules one uh the rest of
them I'm gonna make have you do extracol
chemic TV because we don't have the time
this is normally like a full day course
okay
so why Ray I think they are when when
when the original researchers were
working on this particular project at
Rice lab
they were quite prescient about sort of
thinking about three industry trends
that were sort of dominating at that
particular time we're talking about 2016
to 17 and this was prior to to spark
which was about 10 years earlier and
they realized that machine learning is
pervasive is going to be perversive and
and it's true today ml is everywhere
right it's on your laptop it's an
industry it's in robotics it's in health
science all over the place it's a
pervasive thing and larger and larger
compute infrastructure is actually
needed to build large language models or
or models today are getting larger so
you need a lot of compute power and that
necessitates that that if you're going
to be doing machine learning at a large
scale
distributed computing became a necessity
it wasn't you know it was an exception
in the older days you know you used HPC
or use MPI to write and you really had
to be very
expert in the able to write this due to
the application today it is a necessity
and if something is actually in a
necessity and it's going to be
ubiquitous as as machine learning is
today you have to make sure that you can
actually use it easily and I would
contend that python because you're here
today is the default language right for
machine learning if you look at all the
Frameworks out today all of them
actually have python bindings there
might be implemented in C plus plus that
might be implemented in C but they do
have python bindings as a first class
Citizen and that is the default language
so those were the three primary sort of
pillars or foundational ideas that
actually draw into the evolution of Rey
at that time
now we are blessed with what I would
call the blessings of scale now if you
look at the chart you know on on the far
left hand side and how actually the the
models have evolved today your laptop
can do anywhere from 10 billion to maybe
100 million instructions per second
floating Point instruction second
but when you come to building large
models a lot of machine learning both
statistics traditional statistical
models and today's you know Foundation
models we are talking about exponential
way in which you actually need that but
these blessings of scale kind of also
introduce another problem which we call
supply and demand
now we know that Moore's Law is dead
rest in peace he passed away last week
um and we can see that the GPU so have
somehow was meeting some of that
particular demands and the hardware
accelerators like the TPU kind of met
that particular demand but if you look
at the linear scale in which the the the
the the the the compute power is
actually needed it's about 35x every
month and there's a huge gap right
there's a huge gap between what the
today's accelerators can provide you and
what the demands of this particular
models are and we contend that the only
way you can actually do that if you
actually go distribute it right you only
have to to distribute otherwise you just
can't do it you have to go across the
entire cluster
and the third one was the pi data
ecosystem right you can actually see
some of you actually have worked with
this particular libraries you're working
with these libraries and these are the
sort of the traditional libraries that
you actually use to do your you know
your your number crunching or your data
Transformations and the library is on
the right hand side all they have python
Bindings that allow you to do machine
learning boards statistical and deep
learning as well so that was sort of the
third Trend that people actually saw
going
so I've talked about why Ray right what
was the foundation what was the
philosophical reason of of doing that
and we're actually beginning to see the
the massive adoption array today for
doing machine learning at scale
so I'm gonna switch about the wood
history right
what is Ray I've talked about why Ray
and what is Ray and I think one thing I
want you to take away from this
presentation if not anything else it's a
simple general purpose library for doing
distributed computing
and it comes out of the box with three
kinds of abstractions that we're going
to talk about today they're going to
have workshops on and the library is
actually built on top of that for you to
be able to do scale your machine
learning workloads now when I talk about
machine learning work tools what am I
talking about I'm talking about data
ingestion data transformation I'm
talking about doing batches and
distributing your data across workers in
the cluster where they can actually do
training so there's a library for that
we're talking about batch inference or
or hyper parameter tuning is another big
Library tune that comes out of the box
but it's actually built on the record
Primitives we're talking about
reinforcement learning which is an
important part today in both building
Foundation models but also in the gaming
industry and in other areas where you're
actually solving and optimizing problem
and you're learning as you actually go
along and the good thing is it actually
runs on your laptop is as though today
you're going to be running running on
your laptop it runs on any of the public
Cloud they actually have it's open
source you can run it on premise and you
can run on kubernetes
but another way to locate it is layered
kicker functionality and what I mean by
layer cable functionality right
at the bottom you actually have all the
clouds that you can actually run on and
then one level a bow is the rare core
and we're going to talk about what Ray
core is today
and Ray core sort of provides you these
abstractions to allow you to write your
python application convert them into
either tasks which are stateless
functions or actors which are stateful
actors and then the objects is a shared
memory that is across the cluster and
we'll get into that
and this is sort of the ray core on
which these libraries are built right so
if you go one level above we have this
thing called Ray air which is a unified
toolkit that allows you to build these
ml applications so you can do data
training transformation you can do train
you can do tune serving our lib and if
you don't care about this thing right if
you're not a machine learning programmer
let's say a physicist or you are a
geologist or you're a climate
climatologist we have one in the room
um who wants to scale the python
applications to do numerical
computations you can use Python tasks to
do that so it sort of so two purposes
you can actually use rate to build your
machine learning libraries using the the
existing libraries and they're very work
very cohesively or you can just use Ray
to do other distributed tasks and just
to give you this architecture diagram in
the ray air I'm talking about has got
all these different Integrations that we
actually have that allows you to do end
to end so for Ray data you can use any
of these libraries that actually are
integrated with Ray
for training we have Integrations with
pie chart xgboost any of the popular
library that you actually are using
today to build both your statistical or
traditional model or also using deep
learning models as well and if you're
doing hyper parameter tuning we have a
tuning library but you can actually
provide your schedulers you can provide
your search algorithms you can provide
any of the third-party algorithms that
are provided by this library that you
can actually work with tune so if you're
doing a massive hyper parameter tuning
and let's say you want to use Asha
scheduler and you want to use early
stopping and you want to provide a
search grid on which you can do that you
can do that with Ray tune this is sort
of the advanced one and if you do
experiment in tracking which is an
important part if you're building
machine learning models today you need
to track exactly how what parameters you
use all the artifacts you actually
created and so we have Integrations with
that we don't provide that as part of
the rape but we provide Integrations you
can actually do that
and so on and so forth down the line and
these are sort of very scalable because
they run on top of rates so you can
actually scale them across so that sort
of is is the whole idea behind it the
very high level you know what Ray is all
about
now I'm going to go down a little into
what the ray architecture is because I
think it's important for you to
understand behind the scenes how things
actually laid out
right now if you look at this this
architecture it's no different from any
other Computing distributed company that
you have you know such as dasco such as
Apache spark the idea is that you're
going to have workers and the workers
will be executing some job on the top of
that but there's something quite unique
about about this particular Anatomy is
that the headphone actually has the
driver and the worker and the worker can
be any python process that's bound to a
CPU so if you have eight CPUs you can
have eight python work that's working
there is a rail at which actually has
two threads one is a scheduler another
one is an object store and scheduler is
responsible for managing and scheduling
tasks in actors and making sure that
that your tasks are scheduled at to a
particular node where you actually have
enough resources and the object store is
a shared memory Object Store which is
built on top of Apache plasma and the
object store allows you to store any
objects that you should always check
greater than 100 kilobytes so you can
share this object store across you
actually have a shared memory store that
goes across and then when objects are
created they actually put in the object
store if you have processors running on
the same worker or any workers running
on on the same particular work node they
can get the objects though zero copies
you're not copying it there's no IPC
going on between processes they just use
the shared memory and that's something
quite unique about that none of the
other distributed systems have that you
have a distributed schedule you don't
have a main scheduler there's any of the
raillets can actually schedule your so
you have a distributed schedule you have
now distributed object store where you
can actually share any objects that you
actually put in and then there is a
global store that has think of it it's a
meta information about
what processes are anywhere what tasks
are running where what are the resources
what are the GPU resources anytime when
when raillet wants to schedule something
it consults the object store and
periodically every 10 milliseconds the
objects so broadcast
um the the current state of of all the
resources how many Hardware resources I
have how many gpus I have and if a new
if a new worker comes in to register
itself with the global object store and
then actually educate broadcast so the
ray let at any point has an idea of what
is my resource across the entire cluster
and this all happens behind the scene
you don't have to worry about it Ray
sort of takes care of that
so that's the anatomy of the cluster
and now as I want to get into some of
the design patterns that Ray supports
and you probably have seen those design
patterns in other programming language
and what's so unique about about that
with Ray and how it actually projects or
translates that into apis
so some of you probably have heard about
this design patterns if anybody you read
this particular book
right so design patterns were introduced
in our Consciousness
um by this gang of four right and they
sort of introduced this this high level
concept of how design patterns are used
in high programming languages and in Rey
you actually have three design patterns
that that we share and we Implement you
know one is the parallel Ray tasks and
rate tasks are nothing but any python
function that you have you can convert
that into a distributed setting and that
allows it to run cluster across allows
you to run tasks across the cluster and
that can actually scale and these are
stateless right I mean which means that
there's no statement in
the second thing I talk about is the
array object as Futures and Futures are
something they probably have come across
if you're using Scala or if you're using
today's python features that's something
that materialize uh later on down down
down the the time of your machine of
your application and they can be fetched
when they actually materialize and those
are normally blocking holes and this
ability to do asynchronously allows you
to paralyze stuff so the combination of
parallel rate tasks and the ability for
the tasks or access to create these
features as objects that that you they
might get might return they are stored
in the object store so we can just
schedule something it will go and do the
tasks when the um when the tasks are
ready you can actually go and fetch them
and then reactors just extend parallel
Tower so if you have a particular python
class that you have and you want to make
that into a stateful service or a micro
service you can use reactors and that
allows you to do message passing between
actors or between tasks and actors and
these three are the fundamental
abstractions that are the core on which
all the other libraries actually build
and these are sort of the solid core you
know you don't have to worry about
scheduling you don't have a memory
management all that's actually taken
care by Ray itself you just write your
functions or write your your python code
using these abstractions and we'll see
some of that in the workshop
and there's some links over here by the
way the slides are in the GitHub there
is a slide directory if you go to the
directory there is a pi data Seattle
directory you can always get to the
slides if you want to follow along
now some of the scaling design patterns
which are very common that you actually
have either worked with or you have you
have encountered are what we call
scaling design pattern one is what we
call different data same function right
this is very common for your machine
learning workflows such as batch
training and inference what you're doing
is you're actually taking a large data
set that you actually have you're
creating into shards and you're using
the same function or the same model or a
copy of a model which is across the
cluster and you're predicting it or
you're doing inferencing or you're
you're your batch inference different
data same function right A variation of
that is you're using the same data but
using different functions so let's say
you actually want to train two or three
models you know you want to do a linear
linear regression you want to do XC
boosting decision Tree on the same data
but you want to use different hyper
parameters to to make sure that you can
train those different models so over
here using the same data you're training
three different algorithms or three
different functions and you're getting
the end result at the back and you're
picking the best one
and the batch training is no different
right batch training is that you
actually want to use different data but
the same sort of function so when you do
distributed training you want to take
the data you want to Shard it and you
want to give it to the same model to the
same function of your objective function
to do the training so this is sort of at
a high level what it is and we'll go
through some of the exercises that are
in the workshop so those are sort of the
design scaling patterns I talk about now
how does that translate into the apis I
talked about the three design patterns I
talked about how do they translate into
python code so you have a python
function just you know some random
function I have a class and then I have
some numpy assignments that I want to
now convert that into its Ray equivalent
and all I need is I just put the
decorator core radar remote
and then what radar remote does or at
least what the driver does or whatever
this thing is is doing the ray light
will actually schedule this particular
task on any one of the nodes that you
actually have
all right simple as that you don't
really remember the IP address you don't
have to worry about where the ray
cluster is you don't have to worry about
the way the record worker node it
um you can just do that by doing radar
remote the second bit is I talk about
stateful functions is where you actually
take a class that you actually have and
you want to maintain a particular state
and you just do the same thing you
decorate that we did a remote and that
converts that into a distributed service
or distributed Object Store running on
each and every node now each and every
instance of a reactor you create will
will have a different instance running
right one instant would be schedule on
one node if you create another instant
there'll be a schedule on the third note
and so on and so forth
and then finally
if you have
data that you actually want to store and
distribute as distributed object stores
that other workers in the cluster can
get access to it all you do is you use
these very simple apis very put and reg
get and then these will be somehow
stored into a particular array object
node with that particular data on it and
then any worker running on that
particular node can actually use row.get
if the object a and if object a is
created on node a let's say it's a
process running a node B that requires
node a then the primary copy is copied
over and then once that you actually
pretty much will have it across so
there's an initial
um
overhead of coping it over but once you
actually have that you'll have shared it
across so those are sort of the Ray apis
I talked about any questions
yes
after objects is that sorry uh when the
actor sorry he acted in class or the
actor everything sticks in the class the
actual is an instance of the class right
so when you actually create an actor
you're saying this is my template right
so when I you'll see how we actually
create an instance so when I'm doing a
uh the class.remote see this code over
here cluster remote I'm creating an
instance of that and then when I want to
invoke any of its methods that I have
which is this method I just invoke
the method name and then I pass the
arguments right if I'm in the
construction arguments that I want I
just provide that in this particular
code and it will go ahead and initiate
that with the Constructor so that's a
simple example but we'll see that in the
workshop
yeah so
um good question how does this actually
get shared in the memory let's say this
particular object
gets placed on node a
right and there's a task that's running
on node a it'll be able to use that
object right away there's another task B
running on node a you'll be able to get
that through zero copy because processes
share share shared memory so you don't
have to copy into processing now let's
say there's a Class C or task C which is
running on node B and it needs a
reference to a somehow you know you you
need that particular dog you actually
send it a reference and and and this
task will say well where this particular
node I'm going to find out from from GCS
where this particular note and then it
will ask the ray led to go and copy it
so this particular slide that I had with
the dreylet knows exactly where they
reference it it's going to copy it over
and now this is a secondary copy that I
have right and once that is out of scope
this will go away the primary copy will
remain and so we have a distributed
reference counting and all the
references are gone
yes we are coping yeah you actually
we're using grpc to actually copy data
and once it's over here then then it's
stored in the shared memory
so just just to give you a sort of
illustration what actually happens is
that when you actually create a
particular task you can provide the the
resources that you actually want so here
I said I want to reserve two CPUs for
this because all I'm doing is a plus b
no pun intended but you know I'm just
giving an illustration over here that I
need two CPUs for that particular that
and then what I have is now this is
going to be
scheduled on any one of the worker nodes
that actually has two CPUs result and
it'll start executing that so that's how
that's how
um this particular remote function is
done when it does a plus b Returns what
happens over here is that it will return
right away
asynchronously and it will give you an
object reference and then the object
reference can actually be fetched to get
the result A and B when it materializes
right asynchronously so that's the great
thing about tasks is that you can create
thousands of tasks and all of them will
be scheduled right away and then they'll
start executing and when they when
they're finished they will actually put
their objects in real object store and
then you can actually have an ability
you know in a weight while loop to
actually go and fetch those things
in a similar manner a reactor actually
has the ability to to specify the same
thing our phone number gpus and I want
this particular actor to be
distributed across hosts that actually
have four gpus so when I request the
four gpus what happens at this point is
that the race Ray LED schedulers say
okay
I don't have full resources
so let me
broadcast that to gcp to find out which
raylet actually has four gpus and I'm
going to get a lease from that and then
one that release I get that particular
this the ray light will actually
schedule now that particular remote that
particular host actor to be scheduled on
that particular host so all these things
actually happening behind we really
don't have to worry about it but I just
wanted to give you an intuition of what
happens under the hood
okay let's look at some code right here
we actually have a function that I'm
taking
um
which just takes in
a file and then returns a numpy array of
that and then I have a function called
add that actually takes two references
to it or two values or whatever that is
and then computes the addition of those
and then I'm doing array.get so what's
happening over here well
when radar remote is scheduled it's
going to read that particular file and
it will convert that into a numpy it
will return a reference
right it's not written actually data is
just returning a reference
and then add radar takes two arguments A
and B
and I'm going to add those to numpy rays
and I'm going to return the value and
I'm not going to return the actual value
but I'm going to return a reference to
it an object a future
so when I do read dot array.remote I'm
getting
a reference to it right away right it's
not going to read the file that's going
to start reading the file but what you
would get is is an object reference and
the same thing with file number two and
now note the difference over here is
that I'm not sending the actual values
of the file that's actually read what
I'm sending over here is the object
reference that was actually returned by
these two calls for me and then I'm just
sending the references over here now
when I send the object reference what
this particular array n is going to do
is that oh I've got an object reference
it's not actually available so I'm going
to do references I'm going to find out
where this object reference is and if
you look at the object reference we have
an encoded value how it's actually done
and it's going to get the value of those
numpy arrays after you've read from the
file and return you and then when I get
the value back the addition note that
I'm doing a rate.get
all right now radar get at this time is
a blocking call because I don't know
whether the value returned by this has
already materialize and I don't know the
value written by ID in ide1 above has
already been materialized because it's
the file that's actually reading so this
is sort of one of The Blocking codes
but what happens over here is that these
can be scheduled right away and you get
references back and you just continue
doing that so that's one of the uh sort
of fine bits about that yeah
you
know id1 put in the background you get
return to reference but it actually
starts it will start reading it but you
read it asynchronously right what
happens over here the the read part of
that is is is is scheduled by the redlet
and and you'll just get a reference back
right so this is
no it doesn't wait it just it's yeah you
just get the reference right away right
it'll be like within one millisecond
boom you got the reference right and
then you can do a radar get on it and
you'll see you'll see that it's blocking
but if it's ready you'll be able to get
the data
yeah I mean radar is just saying that is
it materialized if it is already
materializing the object store boom
return me the value right
so you're not obliged to call radar get
right away you can call it later down
the line as you're going you're doing
other stuff but this is all happening in
the background asynchronously and that's
the beauty of it because you can create
all these tasks and later on you know
get the values as they're needed
something very similar with with Klaus
actually is that you actually just say
for this particular array remote I want
a counter to have one GPU and then you
write those particular methods and you
create an instance of c and then go
ahead and and increment uh any of the
methods that you have and the way you
increment the way you invoke its method
is just use the function name I mean the
instant just like you do that in in
Python you have an object you create the
method name but over here we just have
the suffix code remote and then have any
arguments do that the same thing over
here in both cases always return a
reference right you always have to do a
radar Gap
and this is this is what we were talking
about is that when this is actually
happens I have readout array that's
actually reading a file and it's going
to return an ID reference right away the
other
um the other array read the other read
array could be a schedule on another
note and this guy's going to return a
reference so there's this Dynamic graph
it's actually building and then we're
actually adding those two numbers and
then returning the value of the
particular reference and then finally
we're doing array.get
you don't know how big that file is in
fact right
um is under a hood raised figuring out
to distribute that over a memory
yeah yeah there's a library called radar
data I mean you actually have let's say
10 gigabyte file sitting on sitting on
S3 what it's going to do is going to
block it's going to read blocks of that
and and and Shard it across across the
red cluster and then return you uh those
particular blocks and we will see some
of the particular example I hope we have
enough time I'm going to run through
this slides very quick and then the
object store that I talked about is this
illustration of what an object store is
and it has a shared memory Object Store
and any of these worker processes on
which a tasks are scheduled or the
actors are scheduled they can access any
of the objects which have been created
by that and this is all zero copy so I'm
not doing inter-process copy now it's
not inconsiderable that that sometimes
you know your object store has a limited
capacity and you're putting in a lot of
lumpy areas you're putting a lot of
images in there and you'll run out of
you'll run out of shared memory and
they'll spill to the disk
right and you can specify with that
particular disk is whether you want it
on S3 or whether you want an EBS storage
or whatever high performance or NFS file
system you actually have mounted in the
cluster that can be actually stored and
then when it's actually stored it's
actually noted in the GCS that this
particular object of your reference that
you have
used to exist on node a but now it's
stored in the in the disk and that's how
you actually get that and then this is
some sort of simulation of how sort of
shared memory actually works
um anybody actually has worked with
shared memory
okay right I mean this was already a
common way of how Unix shared uh data
you know you just create this slash Dev
slash share memory you know provide that
and then you can you can just write
write stuff to it and this is based on a
Apache plasma which is very efficient
and the cold Street are very simple to
get do a put do a weight
and you're done
okay and just to give you an
illustration this is actually what's
happening in our radar remote function
that I have scheduled so that might be
executed in node two then I'm doing
another remote function so that function
is going to be
um
executed or schedule on that particular
note because Ray actually has an idea of
data Affinity so if if if f is actually
referencing a data that I know is
actually stored over there the relate is
smartly enough to actually schedule it
up there so I don't have to do a copy
across the node
and this is actually what happens over
here the G is going to schedule over
here now it has access to both the data
so that's sort of what's Happening
behind the scene
okay so why would you actually use Rey
I'm going to sort of give you and I just
want to give you a quick high level
before we actually get into the uh the
workshops you can use Ray to build
libraries we actually use that to build
our array of runtime that I talked about
in the slide you can use Ray to to to
build other distributed Frameworks that
you actually hear so for example we have
a version of XC boost array which you
can actually do that XC boost today
allows you to do distributed compute but
on a single node
right you can actually take eight chords
that you actually have and you can
distribute your your objective function
on that or your or your algorithm on it
and it will it will distribute it across
but what about if you actually wanted to
approve the cluster so you know we have
wrapper on that same thing with
scikitlan like joblib allows you to do
that locally but now you can actually do
it across
um Ray actually also you can write
multi-processors pool we actually have
multi-processor pool then Ray so these
are all the ray patterns that allows you
to build those things what are some of
the other things that people actually
use Ray for you know you can use that
for monitoring experimenting you know
people actually have integrated array
with that and then finally you know we
have all these Integrations all these
companies are actually using array to
build their own platform
right because if you provide you the
abstraction you can actually build
additional uh your own existing platform
they actually have we have integration
hugging phase and Pi torch and Alpha and
all those things so that's what people
actually using Ray for
now
it behooves me not to talk about Rey and
not talk about large language models
because I think we have sort of Interest
the Zeiss guys of this foundational
shift
and
luckily Ray is just there at the right
time
so what is the current state of the
world with respect to foundational
models so you got this big tech
companies right you got cohere you got
open AI you got intro Pig you got
hugging phase stability eye every day
there's new coming these are also the
people who actually have deep resources
they have the Deep engineering expertise
they have lots of money and they can
actually use the compute power to build
Foundation model from scratch right and
fortunately when they were when when we
had our race Summit last year Greg
Brockman who was one of the founders of
of cohere of open AI
uh revealed to us publicly that they
were looking at some distributed
Frameworks to figure out how they can
actually train GPT and how they can
actually train
um
chat GPT and then how they can actually
use the reinforcement dealing with human
feedback and they tried many Frameworks
and didn't work scaling just didn't work
and they decided to go with Ray because
it gave them the Primitives to actually
do that so those models were actually
built using red but what about if you
and me want to use language models what
do you do right
we mere mortals actually have two
choices or three choices you know we can
download some of the model from the
hugging phase
right they have pre-ten weights and then
we can fine tune that with our data they
actually want to do either summarization
or we wanted we want to do some q a
instruction set for that and then we can
actually do serve and inference but all
these three things that we can actually
do mere mortals actually has some
challenges that we have to overcome you
know one thing is that scaling can be
relatively costly because you want to
start fine-tuning these particular
models even if there are six billion
parameters or 175 billion parameters you
need you need clusters to virtually
scale and distribute your training so
you can go with you know you can go with
sport instances but sport incidents can
disappear
right and if they disappear you can lose
some of the state so you have to have a
framework that allows you to actually
take control and fall back or or or or
has the ability to recover from those
things and then most of the time if
you're actually using both hardware and
and and CPU and GPU resources sometimes
you might have a a an ideal GPU just
sitting there because your CPU is doing
some computation and it's waiting for a
data to do this GPU inference so you
have to have a framework that can
can can minimize the ideal time and you
can do pipelining things as soon as the
data is available for one it can be fed
into GPU to do that so you actually have
to have the ability to do that the other
thing that models don't exist in
isolation
right if you actually build a particular
model there'll be in samples of model
right you might have a model that's just
doing a prediction and that might take
the prediction and feed it into into one
of the classifiers and the classifier
might give it uh data to that each of
this separate models which are built as
a single unit of execution might need
different different ways you can
actually scale it right so these
replicas that you actually might create
they have to have the ability to scale
automatically so you have to worry about
those things because there might be one
model that's taking a lot of traffic and
you won't be able to scale it and scale
down and then finally you know when
you're doing fine tuning you know
there's a lot of tweaks that you will
actually make do you want to do
distributed training and you also want
to change some of the hyper parameter
tuning so you can actually get the best
um uh pre-tained model and fine-tune
that so these are some of the challenge
for we are Mortals and
what Ray allows you to do and one of the
one of the things that we actually done
is that we try to simplify the
orchestration by making sure that the
sport instances when they fail over we
actually maintain the stand you can
recover from it the ability for you to
actually do inference referencing and
scale it independently right so has the
ability for you to scale independent uh
replicas and then training you know
training and tuning Ray train can has
all the wrappers are on pytorch and and
in tensorflow and XC boost to be able to
do that so if you're writing all this
Boiler code to do DDP with pi torch you
don't have to do that you just use the
raid Pi torch trainer and underneath it
will actually do all the all the Boiler
code for that so the way we actually use
Pi torch is if you're doing data data
distributed data parallel we create the
process groups and then underneath the
python processes do the radiance
synchronization so all that code you
don't have to worry about it that's
that's done for you
and we're beginning to see two emerging
Stacks in the open source Community
today
you've got people who actually want to
be a foundation models from the scratch
they can use Jacks for it they can use
output that allows you to do model
parallelism because if you're building
you know 300 billion parameters you
actually need to be able to do to build
models in apparel or do their inferences
at the same time and they're using Ray
for the orchestration for both GPU and
CPU and then they can actually compile
some of the alpha code that you actually
have and then you can actually run that
on a GPU accelerator so these are the
people actually want to build open
source from scratch these are all open
source stack you're going to use the
thing you have to pay for it is
obviously this thing over here because
that can be here costly
the other stack we actually see you
already have a pre-trained model and all
you want to do is just a little bit of
tuning a little bit of training so you
you download the hugging phase model you
can use the deep deep speed accelerator
that we actually have integrated with
that and you can use the pytorch
framework and then use Ray for
acceleration and then you can use any
GPU that you actually want there your
Hardware that your GPU supports right so
this is building from scratch this is
taking existing stack that you have and
then
um using all open source that you
actually have so that's essentially what
we talk about and what we have done
to verify that to give you a social
proof to give you guidance we have
created a half a dozen blogs that
actually tell you how you can actually
use array for all these things so if you
go to any scale goal you have a series
of this particular blog that give you
the notebook that actually gives you
exactly how to do it and this is a
validation for us to say you know open
source is here right you could actually
work with the proprietary stuff but this
is also good that you can actually use
and these are the companies who are
actually using Ray and we actually have
a specific talk that you actually want
to attend on Friday which will go more
detail into how llm is actually used and
we're going to train a flanntify model
to see how you can actually do that okay
so takeaways
distributed companies are necessity why
because ml is very pervasive our vision
is to make sure that that it's actually
easy for anybody to actually use it and
lay libraries allow you to scale your
machine learning workloads and Ray
offers a compute substrata for generic
workloads okay we have a summit coming
up anybody attended Ray Summit before
okay we have a rare Summit coming up on
on September in San Francisco a good
reason to get out of Northwest and come
down to sunny California uh September
the 15th through 18th I believe when we
have a full day of training so
guys from Denmark you guys can come over
okay let's go to the code now any
questions before I get into uh the
workshop
yeah
um
are there any libraries and integration
yeah so when you're running when you're
doing rayon kubernetes there is a cube
reoperator that allows you to to do that
right so there's a cubery operator that
that can that can scale your your pods
actually want so if you're running on
kubernetes with Ray you use a cubery
operator to do the orchestration
and if you're using rare sub to to
um
scale the replicas there's a race of
operator that does that so yeah we work
with Cube Rivers that's why so you can
actually run on kubernetes with with the
kubri operator and that was a community
contribution from Microsoft and and I
believe Google and and in any skill
yes
I can't hear you
so uh there are some workflows that I
could Implement in spark yeah
maybe in particular you mentioned that
XG boost is implemented there's an
execution implementation for array
there's also one for sparse
yeah good question I think there's
certain workloads which which are very
good for spark right so if I was doing
say
ETL and Ed I wouldn't use Ray because
Ray is not equipped for that if there
are certain batch inferences you're
doing for
um at a massive scale then Rey accepts
that we actually have some performance
numbers which are going to come out next
week we've written pretty good brokes
you actually see how we have compared
both Ray Apache spark Ray and and
sagemaker to do batch inference at scale
and then give you the the performance
number the other you know the other
workloads like data transformation and
all that actually does vary right so if
you're using pandas if you're using pie
pandas you can use a particular spark
but today you have more than which is
distributed Panda so you can actually
use modern modern Monterey right so the
owl there's uh differences you actually
think about that and the other problem
is you now actually have two different
clusters you've got a spark cluster you
got a red cluster right I look at it
this way and this is you know I'm I'm a
big fan of sparking because I worked
there for saying it and wrote a book
once bar I look at it this way is that
they're very complementary you know the
the spark does good things with certain
things and I believe that the Journey of
of a machine learning data scientist
ends where the the Journey of the data
engineer ends so once your ETL is done
once your data is cleansed everything is
ready in in the case of actually
bootstructured data sitting on the table
in S3 or or in a Delta Lake you can now
hand it off to to to the ray to be able
to do that training because now you
already have the trainer you might use
Last Mile transformations
right where you might want to you know
change the image or you might want to do
some do some some scaling of the image
those can be done with Ray data that
allows you uh has the preprocessors that
run with the training Loop so yes
they're all those things I don't have
the numbers but next week we might have
numbers in one particular workload
I don't have one for the XC boost
um can you can you talk to me I might
have something in documentation that we
actually did some numbers but it's no
comparison we just saw some numbers on
Ray where they're more about how XC
boost on One Core obviously one six core
obviously what are course distributed
but now we haven't done those
comparisons
because one of the things that when you
run distributed training on on Apache
spark you use horror wood on top of that
right
because you have to use horrible to do
the distributed training and that allows
that that's an additional uh layer that
you actually put in here to take into
account
any other question
okay how many of you are successful to
put
um
spark not Sparks hooray see this all
happens when you work for a company for
too long you can't get the things out of
your head
um how many of you put Ray on your on
your laptop
okay this is optional I mean I just
wanted people to somehow you can follow
along by just going to the particular
notebook that you actually have
so these actually had three modules
we're not going to cover all of them
I'll try to cover at least the first
three if I had the time we have about 45
minutes so let's go into into the first
notebook
okay I can see the screen
okay so you've seen this particular
slide all I'm actually doing is is
showing you how you can actually take an
existing Ray application that you
actually have which is serially in
Python and then convert that into into a
parallel execution and the task of
parallelism pattern is very simple you
can actually either have one worker
that's executing all these particular
tasks or you can actually have array
schedule all this tasks on different
workers and now you actually think
executing parallel so this is the
parallel execution versus versus serial
execution and we'll get some of the
examples of that and the way you uh the
way you actually do that is is if you
actually have a function once you
actually
put the ray decorator on that you can
actually use the the function
name.remote to be able to just send
arguments to that to to execute remotely
so we're going to do something very
simple and generate the the lazy uh
Apache I mean uh Fibonacci series so I
have about 10 million
100 000 numbers that I want to create in
the Fibonacci Theory and I'm just going
to create this particularly generic
python function that is going to take my
Fibonacci number and then calculate
those Fibonacci series and then return
me the length I'd only written all the
numbers because it's just going to be
too big but I'm just going to return the
length which is going to be 100 000. and
then I have a remote function which all
I'm doing is I'm just decorating that
particular function so that I want to
now run it remotely
so we're going to do that and I want to
find out how many CPUs do I have so I
can create that many
tasks separately so I have 10 of those
right so that gives me train and then
I'm going to have another function as I
said run this locally right and then
this particular code I'm just using
um comprehension to go ahead and create
10 tasks serially each of these are
going to compute you know a Fibonacci
series for 10 000. this is just an
illustration to see how long it actually
takes running sequentially in parallel
so let's run this in local mode and then
time it and you'll actually see that it
took about one
1.9 seconds to do 10 tasks to compute
all the Fibonacci series for that
so now let's actually do that for Ray
cluster did I actually start the cluster
I normally you know whenever I'm doing
more notebooks I go ahead and sort of
restart the the cluster on my on my
laptop so I start everything from
scratch
and there is a dashboard that actually
comes with that and we'll get into that
in a minute it actually shows you the
metrics and all that all right so we did
that serially now what about we actually
do that run remote in a distributed
manner and so when we when you do a run
remote what am I doing over here
so the Run remote is doing exactly the
same thing but the only difference over
here is that I'm executing 10 different
tasks remotely
and each of them will get 10 000 numbers
and it will execute in parallel and then
I'll get my results back as as the
object reference so that's what actually
is happening over here
so we're going to run that
you can say 25 milliseconds right now
the difference between
the wall time over here and the wall
time over there you say well why there
is a difference between those two this
particular old time takes into account
that remember you're actually doing your
radar get which is a blocking call
right and that's where the additional
time is but you can say there's a
significant difference in something
executing serially and something
executing using Ray
now for exercises normally we when I
have this all day workshop you know we
we break at this point and you guys
start doing the exercises but I have
Solutions over there so you can actually
look at that tonight if you actually
want let's do something else let's do
something interesting let's see if we
can actually compute the the value of pi
using the same mechanism using serially
and then using in parallel and the way
we actually compute using Monte Carlo
simulations is that we try to to get as
many spots or in many data points
between this one by one square and the
concentric Circle if they're inside then
we can actually do that and we take a
ratio of that and then compute what the
pi is and so we're going to take again
10 tasks because we have I have 10 CPUs
if you have 20 CPUs you can actually do
20 CPUs
I'm going to cook it at about 10 million
data points I want to you know as many
data points as I have I'll probably have
a better approximation of Pi
and then so my total number of samples
is going to be my total number of tasks
I'm going to run times times the number
of number of
data points
and then I'm going to use this
particular function to determine if the
data point random data point between -1
and 1 falls into that particular Circle
and if it does then I just compute that
and if it doesn't then then I go
I go home right so let's do that run
serially and again seriously I'm doing
the same thing we're actually using a
comprehension list to go ahead and and
create 10 tasks serially and each task
I'll just assign a task ID so I know
this is Task 1 tiles 2 and then we're
sending the same sample size up to the
serial and we're going to go ahead and
do that
and likewise
um for distributed we are just going to
put
a rear decorate on top of that and then
return an object and an object over here
is is whatever is returned by by the the
sampling function
and the Run distributor does couple of
things here right first first it
actually does is does the same thing as
the serial one in a comprehension list
and then I'm just putting array.get
around it now notice that I'm actually
doing array.get after all of them have
been executed if I put radar get inside
what do you think will happen
even block on each and every call right
so you'll just wait for it to finish
whereas over here I'm saying go ahead
and schedule all those things and when
you're done with it
when I get back my objective reference
because what this will happen is that it
will go in and schedule all these 10
tasks remotely and return me the object
reference right away and then I'll just
do rate.get and when I do rate I'll get
I'll get the sample of that and I just
took the sum of all those and I'll find
out
so the way we cook it at the pie
is to take a ratio of those things and
now let's run this
cerealing so when we run this cereal you
know you can see that the task ID
so the first sample task ID took about
what
seven days seven million of those
so these are all the data points that
fell into that particular particular
inscribed Circle within the square
and this is all actually happening
serially and you'll see a difference
between the parallelism of that and then
we actually estimate pi
okay so we got the value of Phi up to
five it's again with this in not bad now
let's try to run this and run this in a
distributed manner
right same thing
we're going to run this in distributed
Manner and you can actually see now that
there are 10 different tasks
each of this is a different process now
because I'm running this on my laptop I
have 10 processors running each has a
paid ID but if I had clusters then this
would actually be running on a
particular cluster right so I have 10
tasks although you can see they're sort
of all running asynchronously they've
been scheduled
and then it took about what 42
millisecond compared to what it took me
for the serial one so you can see the
difference between you know running
something seriously and running in
parallel in a very simple manner right
all you had to do was just decorate your
your classes or your functions and you
would actually do that
so just to recap you know you can
actually use these array raid decorators
to be able to take any of your functions
that you have and then convert that into
a distributed set